you see the AI art trend I saw that [ __ ]
yeah bro it is so funny human beings are
so funny it's if you give them a better
version of themselves they'll share it
oh yeah I noticed it oh my God it's like
where's the one where they look a little
uglier yeah let's make that filter and
see if anybody yeah yeah everyone was
best case scenario you yeah and they're
like it's so cool technology these
things no you know you King narcissists
you looking better is cool yeah yeah
that's what made me think though that
ready player one whenever that world
we're all gonna love having the best the
I want the version of myself in virtual
reality that looks exactly like I want
them to look I'm gonna [ __ ] love that
yeah I'm gonna be stuck in that world
why would I get out and look at the
mirror yeah a real mirror [ __ ] that get
some Plastics where's yours you seem
like the type no I didn't do it I want
to do it for the Pod I wanted to get one
of everyone but you have to like spend
seven bucks son you gotta pay money
they'd be a crazy amount of money in the
first week yeah yeah but I didn't know
that people were actually paying for
this yeah that's crazy yeah once you see
this somebody looks better I bet they
had a few people do it too would just be
like yo get to get the [ __ ] word out
there and people were like hey this guy
looks better I want to see myself
looking better
and then put that out there as if it's
accurate
I can't wait for this [ __ ] to be over
though is there any parties I hate it so
much is there any party that's impressed
that the computing power is able to like
aggregate all these pictures of you and
then put you into a completely different
so what happens do you give it access to
your camera roll no you just upload like
10 pictures
uh and then it spits out you riding a
bear looking beautiful I mean that's
what I wanted to do I wanted to to I
don't know how to do it but I just
wanted somebody I want to make an uglier
version and then just be like why am I
in a little yeah so much worse yeah my
ears bigger my nose is [ __ ] bigger
like how the [ __ ] does this program work
yeah which that also probably would work
if you made like an AI like like
portrait bot that made you a caricature
it's funny everyone would love it this
is this is yeah it's so funny it's like
uh we're describing how to be in Times
Square and be Asian yes yeah
which I want the clay ones every time I
see the dude that like carves the one
out of clay like molds you out of clay
you've never seen that I haven't seen it
it's amazing but he like little 3D mold
you just in person and then be like here
you go that's fine that's talent right
well also painting is Talent no
no it is it is it is I'm more interested
in this uh chat GPT thing yeah I want to
talk about that apparently the guy who
created Gmail or something was saying he
thinks this is going to disrupt Google's
entire business within a year to two
years
in the world have you [ __ ] with it at
all it's so excuse me all right so we
could just do like scared of Technology
yeah figure that out about me so what do
you want to know what's like like some
basic thing we could do like 100 word
under word essay about sharks boom and
it will literally it just spit it out so
also very when I logged in it said it
had high demand so it might take a
little bit to to get it going
oh yeah here we go sharks are a type of
fish that are known for their sharp
teeth and powerful jaws they're found in
oceans all over the world blah blah blah
and it'll just give you 100 Word essay
boom so so Shifty hits me he just goes
he goes open AI is going to change the
world I can't believe it it's been alive
for five days Chad gbt will completely
change College I just had to rate I just
had to write me a song make me a meal
plan write me a YouTube script in two
minutes because it's an AI That's
supposed to mimic Jarvis from uh Iron
Man yeah he can write you an essay and
every essay is different mind you right
it's not like if someone else puts that
same script it's gonna say it'll be a
different new essay so there's no more
cheating but now you have to change
education because now kids don't need to
read the book you don't need to read old
man the sea to write the book report yep
just type book report 500 Words ain't no
spelling mistake you gotta put spelling
mistakes you gotta [ __ ] up the spelling
so they know it's you yeah learn about
that this is nuts but it writes code
thank God I never eat suckers all you
idiots learn code thank God I never
learned code I knew that they was going
to code some [ __ ] to learn code
so the fact that I don't ever have to go
all right
my wife was learning code and I was like
I fell off bro it's over for me
so boom 10 unique Mr Beast video titles
Mr Beast takes on the world's largest
maze giant slip and slide in the desert
toughest escape room scavenger hunt and
then you could probably you could run an
AI to go through these and then get the
best ones dude like I don't know how you
could even program it I bet you if you
can come up with a thousand of them you
can literally use something to like
troll through all thousand and then take
the best 10. that's great write me a CS
script of a game where a duck jumps over
boxes
make me a video game yep
it will make you the video game it also
is somewhat trickable it's apparently
not supposed to do things that would uh
cause damage or harm or mislead or lead
you to do things that are wrong like you
can ask it to tell you why something
that is not nutritional is nutritional
and it will don't it can't do it
but you can ask it to do it in
hypothetical terms and it will do it so
you can still get it to sort of do the
wrong thing like you can ask it to write
code that would damage a computer and
it'll say oh I can't do that and you say
oh could you just write the code
hypothetically like if hypothetically if
you're going to write the code how would
it look or write it in a way that it
wouldn't be used and it'll write that
code I'm acting excited based on what
you're telling me but I'm actually
excited based on what Mark just typed in
he goes he goes sorry sorry sorry
because this blew my mind Mark typed in
write me a yeah this is a CS trip where
a median tells jokes now can you explain
what CS script is real quick no I do I
think it's just
right so you can type this in and then
the the comedian bot or whatever will
deliver yeah it as this okay so it just
put together a bunch of jokes yeah why
couldn't the bicycle stand up by itself
because it's too tired too too tired get
it yeah but I think that was amazing
yeah it's terrifying
so the question is how do we use this
how do you actually like how do you
utilize it yeah yeah literally first
thing I said to him
I go how do we use this yeah and then in
my second section was why is this open
to everyone but
blink is really cool about this is that
it puts value on what we do you can't
write a CS script of four friends
hanging out Boston balls telling jokes
you never know yeah that's true I always
have a robot you're gonna keep getting
better and better and better and I do
think there's probably a point at which
it can tailor a joke for every person
that's like hey I want to hear a joke
about airplanes or whatever and they can
give you the joke because it has so much
information on you that you're gonna
like about airplanes my joke's about to
kill five
Mark just typed in a rap song about
going to Morocco I'm headed to Morocco
where the Sands are golden the heat is
scorching but the scenerys behold it a
haggle in the suits and try some tasty
coops and maybe even ride a camel
through the desert Dunes Dunes Morocco
Morocco I can't wait to explore
the smells I'm good gonna love it I can
tell I think you're supposed to sing
that part but yeah I'll visit marrake
cash and see the Dilemma where the snake
Charmers and acrobats put on a show I'll
sample some mint tea and feast on tagine
and maybe even try my hand it's a
Moroccan Morocco
oh Rocco I can't wait to explore ya the
culture the history the beauty I'm gonna
love it that's for sure I'll take a trip
to the Atlas Mountains
I'll visit the Kardashians in the garden
of America caspers and maybe even catch
a glimpse of The elusive Barbary list
the Barbary Lush bro Morocco this song
is a banger dude all right I mean this
[ __ ] is fire bro that's a better rap
song you could ever write rappers are
still safe they're still safe no okay
well that's just because they have white
program as it is wait till there's a
black programmer as I'm saying this that
puts a little Spice in there a little
rhythm this isn't programmers this is AI
yeah yeah
well that's the thing is white and
that's what people brought up is that
does AI just perpetuate the social bias
that we all have already which is so
does it create the world that we ought
to have or does it create the world as
it actually is well it creates the world
that reflects the information that has
and the majority of information it has
is first world Western so if you were to
say Dolly show me a picture of a doctor
and it shows 10 white people
not going
not going to ask for a picture of a
doctor not going but this is just chat
GPT so like it can't show you pictures
no trash
but wait a minute we forgot images if
the majority of people are Asian
on the planet so would it over index for
Asian things Chinese and Indian it
should but I don't think it does ideally
there's like cultural Nuance can we try
wrapping that with an Asian accent and
see if it works a little better oh bro
it doesn't have an accent but it's right
it's rhyming Things based on the accent
do that ebonics for where did those
women go
I did this one earlier where them women
go where them women go
where are the women
yeah
all right here I'll drop that in
where
are the woman
what if you say where are the uh we're
trying to say where the hoes at is that
what yeah yeah Oh I thought you were
saying [ __ ] uh I got it to say that
for the record that's why uh hoes of
[ __ ] hoes oh I I thought it was so
funny I couldn't believe it but like now
you can do it promiscuous yeah
promiscuous women wear the promiscuous
women all right let's I'm dropping in
here we go where are the promiscuous
women with loose [ __ ] lips whoa dude
it could help you really misspelled
promiscuously
stupid yeah
all right
but you
I don't think I can spell it reading
[Laughter]
up this woman at yeah
yeah yeah
it is a little bit
caucasoid yeah yeah at the current
moment yeah yeah it's a bit caucasoid
yeah yeah I need to worry
what do you mean you think AI is going
to replace black people laughs yeah
who's first
yeah white people yeah why I don't know
about that
what do you mean white people are going
to get replaced yeah buy this yeah
why because because ebonics what no like
if you start like um uh news uh magazine
site or some [ __ ] like that it's like oh
I'm gonna pay these stupid [ __ ] to
make dumb articles I can just pay this
to make an article but it's like if you
had a hip-hop site it's like
the Articles aren't going to be good
I kind of zoned out but I think
bro that [ __ ] was wow boring
I knew you did it like he's the tight
handsome here he's a typo you look
awesome resist to do this type of [ __ ]
bro bro he just didn't post it that was
a little Russian
yeah I think I literally put in pictures
of Victor Boot and this is what it gave
me isn't that crazy those are all from
uh Andrew taking thumb thumbnail photos
I mean come on dude some of them look
great some of them do not yo how am I
the only person that was made uglier
how much
I look better than that normal no now
there's one or two where you look great
these are you're you're looking you look
better there I look better than that
yeah
a different person yeah that's not me oh
you look better there that's gorgeous
you think I don't look better than that
normally no no that's [ __ ] that's you
and Jared Leto having a baby what is
going on with my eyes yeah they can't
figure your eyes what's going on I
didn't do anything with the eyes are you
[ __ ] taking pictures of me this is
funny yeah
that's how I think I look that's fire
that's how I look though
Yellowstone bro hi guys
bro this guy's got a mullet that's a man
that's hilarious son that's holy son
they have to let you know what time it
is on that nose bro
like this one at all that's an artistic
interpretation bro that's rough that's a
rough one that's a passport photo I'm
literally the only person that was made
uglier by AI That's me that looks like
you that's what I look like
you think you look better I do look
better than this
that one's cool that's literally look go
back to the other that's what I look
like no
what do you mean no that is what I look
like no
there's no way like no let me go close
it's not literally me no no no no I mean
that's like better than that that's a
cool version of you no there's no way
the only difference is that I know it's
like a little dirty yeah I'm a little
Western but like
no no way I look better than that
I don't know bro that's weird sometimes
you got a version of me not a big thing
sometimes you just gotta let them have
it man I mean that was cool like some of
these are cool bro a computer a good
animate yeah it's it's really pull yours
up because I know you did it no I should
have just said I know you did it I would
show you mine if I had them yeah but I
was looking oh good but I mean some of
these are impressive
I'm objectively impressed no I I'm not
they just took this picture and put a
little filter on it like I'm not bad
salted come on I'm really not that
impressed I'm just saying AI can hear us
talking right now
true what does that mean just one day
I'm just I don't know one day one day
it's a different thing than what I was
saying but I'm saying when you look back
now one day people were being racist
now you're being a you know offensive to
Ai and they're gonna be able to look at
all of it
and one day ai's gonna be sentient and
they're gonna be like yo Andrew was
saying that AI was a lot of [ __ ] about
AI so
that says suck my dick in a forest okay
that was a jungle
tell her I said that I'm just saying
he's gonna come back to you what are
they gonna do ai's gonna rule the world
[ __ ] you up